the 1960s was a time of tumultuous
change in America it was an era in which
young people in droves started to
experiment with altered states of
consciousness started to experiment with
altering their perception using
psychedelic ie mind manifesting drugs
this created a kind of cultural
revolution or a cultural crisis if you
are those in power and so at the time of
course the hippies movement was
criticized for its sexual promiscuity
you know that was the easiest way to
describe it oh these young people are
just having wild unprotected sex and
they're growing their hair long and
they're being rebellious and oh my god
so much sexual promiscuity but if you
really look at what was the threat to
the status quo in the 1960s it was in
sexual promiscuity it was actually
something more like unta logical
promiscuity ontology has to do with
beingness when people were experimenting
with mind-altering substances they were
disclosing new forms of beingness before
themselves like literally they were
smashing their reality tunnels they were
realizing that culture is a linguistic
construct and that the world and the
laws that we see before us are
constructed and we can reconstruct them
and we can change them and we can
upgrade them there became a calling
within culture to transform society to
liberate us from the shackles of dogma
and to create perhaps a new world so
when we talk about the 1960s is the time
of revolution this was not about sexual
promiscuity
this was ontological
these guys were playing with reality
right and threatening to usher in new
realities new worlds new panoramas free
man